when the White House hosted a meeting of
sheriff's from across the country last
February President Donald Trump joked
about destroying the career of a Texas
state senator who supported reforms to
civil asset forfeiture laws the
controversial practice where police can
seize cash and property of people
suspected but in most cases never
convicted or charged with a crime one
who is named will destroy his career so
I was on the Senate floor and we were
waiting to get gavel din and I just kind
of flipped them through my Twitter and
all the senators like what state senator
Connie Burton was one of many local
lawmakers outraged by Trump's comments
which also made national headlines and
angered plenty of state lawmakers far
away from Texas such as Pennsylvania
state senator daylin leach she tweeted
hey at real Donald Trump I opposed civil
asset forfeiture - why don't you try to
destroy my career you fascist lupus
patient-- given while Trump's comments
were meant to support police they've had
the opposite of their intended impact
its reenergized the push for reform when
you give law enforcement the ability to
take your property without a conviction
that's big government Bern is leading
the campaign to reform civil asset
forfeiture laws
she's a tea party leader from the Dallas
Fort Worth area who also happens to be
pro-life and probe orders Burton isn't
the unnamed state senator Trump offered
to destroy but she's emerged as the
state's fiercest opponent of civil asset
forfeiture we are giving law enforcement
the ability to take property and keep it
without a criminal conviction it's up to
the person that you have taken the
property from to prove that their
property has not been involved in the
crime I don't know how you prove a
negative when she explains how these
laws work to her constituents
she says they can hardly believe it like
what you know this is going on yes it's
going on this is why we need to fix it
last December
Burton filed legislation that would
require prosecutors to obtain a criminal
conviction for cops to seize property it
takes civil asset forfeiture and makes
it criminal asset forfeiture so we don't
touch seizure
police can still seize property that
they think has been involved in a crime
but for them to keep it for it to be
forfeited you have to be convicted of a
crime before they can do that
Texas is tried for years to reform civil
asset forfeiture laws after horror
stories began to emerge about the
practice one of the most horrifying
cases occurred in 2005 when cops took
ten thousand dollars from Javier
Gonzalez was driving to the border town
of Brownsville to make funeral
arrangements for his aunt the cops
didn't find any drugs or contraband in
his car but they pressured Gonzalez to
sign away his rights to the cash under
the threat of a felony money laundering
charge and in 2012 the ACLU settled a
class-action lawsuit against the city of
Timothy Texas where cops illegally
seized nearly three million dollars from
traffic stops involving mostly black and
Latino drivers victims were told they
could either sign their cash over to the
city or go to jail
cases like this have earned Texas a
d-plus from the Institute for justice
for forfeiture laws data from the
libertarian legal organization shows
that the state funnels an average of
forty 1.6 million dollars a year to
local law enforcement agencies as a
result of these seizures some of the
money collected by Texas police
departments goes to pay for items that
have nothing to do with fighting crime
in Texas they bought a margarita machine
they were literally using this money as
their own personal slush fund everybody
is ready for this to be reformed it's
either happened to them they know
somebody that it's happened to once they
find out about what it does you know
they're just like why do we have this
how can this be that that you have to
prove your property is innocent in order
to get your property back you know it's
just upside down and antithetical to
what our country should stand for
[Music]